hello so I got a call from Jeremy Shafer
recently and he called me up and told me
I want to go to the origami USA
convention on the plane ticket and I
call that Rob's world so I said yeah
let's do it and guess what he's going to
when June 21st came I shaved got ready
and headed out to pick him up at the
airport after we had some lunch we then
drove to st. John's University in Queens
New York for the convention we designed
some new boomerangs and we tested them
out in the hall there I also got
attacked by a strain in just our comment
down below if you want to see how it's
made the exhibit there was really
awesome
sort of like an origami Museum they had
all different sections where talented
bowlers showed off their own designs or
even their models that they had
completed it was almost like a zoo with
different animals insects and other
creatures there were large and small
samurai models different characters and
really awesome dragons
[Music]
I also got to meet Satoshi Kamiya who
designs really intricate origami models
of almost anything from birds animals to
even dragons that have scales on them
all from one piece of paper he even did
a car commercial using origami
stop-motion that you might have seen as
you could see the models are really
incredible other designers and folders
did origami pokemons different geometric
shapes and even sea creatures there were
turtles sharks and even this puffer fish
that I really liked they also had mini
or micro origami and models folded from
money as well by far the best part was
getting to meet and greet other folders
like Donny who made me this awesome face
hugger hey guys I'm here with tour self
and my buddy Elliott his torsos little
m16 gun that he made really cool I also
got to teach other people and the first
thing I did was the ninja star boomerang
Wow now there you go there you go that
was better
nice
I also got to teach the ninja tristar
boomerang which wound up being
everyone's favorite I was really amazed
at how neat everyone was and how well
they were able to follow along and make
the ninja Tristar boomerangs
after we finished folding them I then
showed them how to throw it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa nice one nice one Jim
right near the end of the airfoil toss
it out and then catch it yeah that was
great that was great throw whoa you had
it you had it whoa Wow let me see yeah
what happened I wanted to make sure
everyone could catch it so I helped as
best I could
there you go
very good nice job buddy yeah sure Wow
nice job
pick up that you got that Oh with a
little help in practice everyone started
my boomerang clothes
[Music]
Oh
he's getting into it here oh nice
awesome and nice cats go it really
vertical quick urea stuff good good good
nice give it a nice flick nice spin you
want to really spin it good nice get it
nice throw people of all ages wanted to
join in on the fun yes yes thank you
very much
just put your hands out like both of
them flat like this put your hands catch
it right in your hand and let it fall
right in your hand let it fall right in
your hand there you go great job I also
got to host the paper airplane contest
in the first event was the longest
flight on your mark get set and fly
on your mark get set and fly
very good well we got four oh nine four
oh nine the second event was the longest
distance okay
ready on my count on your mark get set
and fly we got two planes over here both
of them look like they're arrows don't
touch this did one other one over here
okay so that is 93 back the last event
was for accuracy on your mark get set
and fly
we then gave away awards to the airplane
contest winners good job for the adults
all right good job Spencer
all right let's do it the next highest
one is 316 good job here you go buddy
good job that's two already distance
good job Shawn there you go buddy
93 feet there you go hope you had fun
you all did really well have some really
nice planes out there and we ended the
convention by catching Jeremy's new
ninja star
[Music]
so I'd like to thank you guys for
watching my blog I haven't done one in a
while but I had such a good time at the
origami convention I'd like to thank
origami USA they actually featured me on
their website and they were really
helpful
I've really enjoyed meeting everyone and
teaching the boomerang especially when
everyone was throwing up and catching
them it was a really good time and I
really enjoyed hosting the paper
airplane contest where people had some
really cool designs it's actually 1:15
in the morning on Saturday June 29th
which is my birthday so yep I'm gonna
try to enjoy my weekend so I hope you
guys also have a great weekend and I
hope you're all enjoying your summer
vacation give the video a big thumbs up
down below if you enjoy it and also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to stay notified
also let me know down in the comments
below if you want to see the new ninja
star boomerang design that I came up
with and I'll see you guys soon